for
his Excellency Peter
pavl
dear colleagues dear colleagues this
morning we have the
pleasure of welcoming Peter pavl the
president of czechia to the European
Parliament thank you president for being
here with us
today this house knows you as a
steadfast supporter of European
values as a staunch
proponent for better security and
defense of our Union
as a strong voice for your country in
Europe and the
world like our European Parliament you
have led in condemning Russia's illegal
and brutal military invasion of Ukraine
and remained a crucial pillar of support
CIA knows only too well the level of
threat we face and how critical it is
for the International Community to stand
as one against oppression and
autocracy last year the Czech presidency
was the driver of groundbreaking
legislation and reform and I will always
be proud of what we managed to achieve
together in this Parliament we have
shown people that we can deliver and
next June the European Parliament
elections will see the greatest exercise
in direct democracy on the continent we
need the people of Europe including
those in czechia to voice their opinion
on their vision for the future of Europe
and to hold this Union to account we
must continue to build a Europe that
represents our value of democracy unity
and hope for all and I know that
together we will manage this so on that
note Mr President allow me to thank you
for your strong voice your personal
engagement and your country's commitment
to our joint European project the floor
is
yours
[Applause]
Madame
President dear
Roberta distinguished members of the
European Parliament ladies ladies and
gentlemen citizens of Europe it is for
me an enormous honor to address today
the plenary session of the European
Parliament an institution that has key
responsibility for shaping our common
European future next year it will be 20
years since my country has been involved
since shap uh in shaping that
future check here today it seems to be a
matter of course but for most of the
last century we were not free to decide
as a country about our
future it is different now although
there are some who tell try to tell us
otherwise I would like to start my
address by thanking the European
family for all the support it has
extended to my
country European integration has been
the main driving force behind the
political and economic transformation of
our country country at the end of the
last
century rebuilding Democratic
institutions laying the ground for free
political competition moving away from
the planned
economy those the main challenges we
were facing back
then to return where we have always
historically
belonged to Europe based on Democratic
and moral
imperative
Europe based on the legacy of
Enlightenment and critical
thinking in Europe where technological
progress would serve to advance our
societies yet uh Europe has not always
been defined by its
ideals far too often did Europeans
resort to
violence the consequences of the two
world wars were tragic
Europe was divided with its eastern half
alienated from its true self abducted by
the Soviet
Union today we are back in the cultural
and political space we have belonged to
for
centuries we are ready to shoulder our
share of responsibility and make every
effort to ensure that our difficult
Troublesome and often bloody history
does not repeat
itself the concept of securing peace in
Europe through Union is not
new as you may know as far as uh in the
15th century the Czech King George of P
cherished the vision of United uniting
European kingdoms into a peace
League based on an early vision of
international law his goal was to
prevent conflicts between uh its members
and to boost their defense against
external
threats in his days his uh peace project
did not
succeed luckily the ultimate ideal of
Peace based on unity and cooperation did
find a later
Incarnation the European idea we know
today is based on the notion of peace
through cooperation solidarity and
respect for human rights and the rule of
law our security and prosperity are
closely
interconnected it is impossible to
achieve one without the
other 23 years ago one of my
predecessors and true European and the
world citizen vaslav hav spoke in this
very building about the need to
constantly reflect and critically
examine European values ideals and
princi
principles since then the urgency of the
task has not
changed it is even more important to
ensure that our citizens can genuinely
identify with the principles we stand
for this is our job as politicians to
explain Europe better and to involve our
citizens if we want to shape Europe we
need uh them to understand it at home
strength of Europe lies in our unity and
diversity this is the key for peace and
prosperity not surprisingly our enemies
know know
this that is why they are constantly
trying uh to undermine our moral and
Democratic Values to make us
weaker honorable members the election
campaign next year will put our
democracies to the test
I hope that it will serve as an
opportunity for all of us to demonstrate
that the European Democratic spirit is
truly
[Applause]
alive we should refrain from simplistic
Solutions and empty
promises the temptation to manipulate
realities for short-term political gain
will be
enormous we all have huge responsibility
to articulate problems as they
are my presidential election campaign
has proved that populism is not the only
uh vehicle to electoral
success next year we will also Mark 20
years since 10 member States including
CIA joined the
EU in a sense we have recently come of
age as members of the European
family we are neither knew nor
inexperienced during our second
presidency of the Council of the
European
Union our uh country showed leadership
and determination in finding Solutions
among member states as well as with you
the European Parliament on many pressing
issues the EU is often labeled as uh
slow and
ineffective yet together we have shown
united we can face the challenges of
today and
tomorrow despite the initial diversity
of views we have managed to reach many
good
compromises not only during the coid 19
pandemic but also
afterwards on energy and food
security just green and digital
transitions sanctions against Russia or
financial assistance to Ukraine
it demonstrate demonstrates our ability
to be efficient Under
Pressure over the next year we will hear
a lot about the benefits that the EU
membership has brought to the 10
countries which joined in 20
2004 however uh this was never a oneway
street let us not forget the benefits uh
the enlargement has brought to to all
member
states not only in terms of prosperity
new markets value chains and skilled La
labor force but also in terms of
security by enlarging our family we have
created strong bonds and a safety
net in the European game no one is to be
left behind and
frustrated we overcome differences
through rational debate and dialogue and
not through the power of weapons as was
the case for
centuries therefore we should thoroughly
pursue this great idea that makes a
strong attractive and respected partner
at Global
stage when the the European Union was
awarded the Nobel Peace Prize in
2012 some people smirked
a decade later we appreciate the eu's
contribution to peace on the European
continent with greater
understanding the European Union is
indeed the most successful peace project
this continent has
witnessed security however can never be
uh taken for granted
three decades ago as part of the
unperformed mission I witnessed
firsthand atrocities uh during the war
in former
Yugoslavia I hoped I would never uh see
another war on European soil in my
lifetime in the year 2000 in front of
the members of the European Parliament
the aforementioned hav stressed that
evil must be confronted as soon as it
has emerged unfortunately Europe failed
to detect the evil in
time the current fullscale Russian
invasion has been nothing but a blunt
and cynical attempt to wipe out Ukraine
its people and its culture off the
map the unprovoked unjustified and in
indiscriminate aggression cannot go
unpunished for decades we have designed
International rules to prevent the
horrors of the second world war to be
repeated in a matter of hours Putin made
an attempt to destroy a sovereign
country and to undermine the world
order he has not prevailed and he shall
not
Prevail I am proud that European
countries small and big have come
together to support Ukraine's fight
against
evil I am also proud of the Czech people
from day one they have shown
unprecedented solidarity and did not
hesitate to provide Ukrainian refugees
with money food and
shelter on a per capita basis CIA has
taken in more people than anybody
else during my speech in the UN General
Assembly two weeks ago I argued that
Ukraine's security is our own
security with several crisis unfolding
because of Russia's expansionism and
unsatisfied Imperial Ambitions every
European citizen has felt the
consequences higher energy bills and
Rising food
prices unfortunately there is even more
at stake it's our
freedom I therefore call on everyone to
continue providing support by all
possible
means if Ukraine fails so will
we and this failure would cost us even
more
let us not be fooled by those who claim
that in the name of appeasing Putin
peace should be achieved by offering
concessions which undermine Ukraine's s
sovereignty and territorial
Integrity in
reality what they are asking for is for
Ukraine to surrender and for us to
resign on our own
principles
this is a grave affront to those
suffering from Russian occupation people
who have been stripped off their civil
rights who constantly suffer abuse and
whose children were abducted to
Russia 85 years ago Czechoslovakia was
in a similar
situation to avoid war some European
Statesmen hoped that seeding vast soes
of czechoslovak territory to Hitler
would satisfy the dictator and result in
a peaceful resolution of the
conflict this hope didn't
materialize peace can never be achieved
on the aggressor
terms if the aggressor succeeds once he
will uh try uh to succeed again and even
further I fir firmly hope that peace
will return to
Ukraine I hope this will be a reality
soon however uh hope is not the
strategy that's why we have to strive
for settlement that safeguards the
necessary conditions for Ukraine's
continued existence in lasting peace and
prosperity Russia Russia must be
defeated in
Ukraine and it must withdraw from
Ukraine Ukrainian Sovereign
territory our European security is based
on partnership uh and
democracy we have created a solid common
defense and security architecture with
NATO and the EU as its main building
blocks it is an imperative to strengthen
the European pillar of NATO and enhance
European
interoperability it is now more obvious
than ever that securing peace cannot be
confined just to our
borders indeed I'm convinced that
pursuing a full-fledged European
perspective of all countries of the
western Balkans and of the associated
Trio it is not only our moral
duty in the long term it is an
investment in security and resilience of
Europe and its
citizens we have already wasted too much
time meanwhile political cult culture in
several countries has
deteriorated it is in our interest that
the candidate countries
succeed their success will be our own
success of course the process cannot be
completed without the necessary reforms
both on on the side of candidate
countries and the Union at the same time
we should not use this as an excuse to
delay the accession
process there is a chance to make bold
decisions at the European Council by by
the end of this
year the debates on the future of the EU
and its enlargement are necessarily
interlined and should be approached in
parallel shaping a new whole Europe is
unimaginable without anticipating the
future European
order enlargement should be seen as an
opportunity to recalibrate the European
idea it should be seen as a chance to
bring about a more uh unified and
efficient
Europe a union that remains ambitious
and
competitive a union that is more
flexible and
proactive a union that is able to react
rapidly when needed a union we are all
proud
of I am confident that after extensive
discussions we will be a able to find
the best way forward for a modern and
strong EU
governance for centuries Europe has
sought uh world uh Domination by
force today it should lead by
example VAV hell who would celebrate his
birthday tomorrow was right to stress
the importance to engage with
citizens this was based on his genuine
belief
uh in strong and emancipated civil
society as the main source uh of the
trust between the people and their
elected
officials today trust is constantly
under attack from disinformation and
numerous attempts to distort the meaning
of words and
deeds if we allow rule of law to crumble
and to be displaced by might is right
or even false is right this could lead
to unforeseen consequences for the whole
of
Europe we uh can all disagree on many
different topics but we should not base
our arguments on lies or false
arguments with the European election
approaching we we are to witness uh the
rise of disinformation created uh and
spread uh with the help of algorithms
and artificial
intelligence this is a real threat we
all must prepare
for constantly engaging with private
companies dominating the modern media
space is crucial to ensure that our
democracy and freedoms including the
freedom of speech are not undermined by
mign
actors in our changing world the main
question remains how to preserve our
openness and uh dismantle uh unnecessary
barriers among ourselves and at the same
time strengthen resilience of our
democracies this is a fundamental
debate I believe that the question of
resilience and sustainability of the
concept of democracy deserves a special
focus in order to confront ever more
assertive behavior of autocrat
autocratic regimes we also need to forge
stronger ties with our natural European
and transatlantic
allies we should suppress uh rivalry and
instead encourage an even closer
cooperation to preserve our common
values the values which are not limited
to any country or
continent a worldwide Alliance of
democratic countries can make make us
stronger and more resilient in uh even
more prominent threats like climate
change or
disinformation we also need to engage
with countries which are already exposed
to a high degree of political economic
and climate
risks while we may not always share the
same views we still need to establish
pragmatic and mutually beneficial
Partnerships including free trade
agreements with relevant
countries wherever we neglect this
requirement we leave the space open for
our strategic
competitors history and nature show that
if uh you want to survive you must be
able to
adapt the same applies to Europe our
security needs are constantly evolving
climate change and economic
transformation expose us uh to a new set
of
challenges over the last 3 years uh we
have uh dedicated our work to setting
the framework for the next
decades with the Fit 4 55 package in
principle adopted our job is far from
being
over we will have to overcome the
insecurities of our people about their
future especially the younger
generation this will be a crucial test
of whether we can reconcile our degree
of ambition with
credibility politicians will have to
demonstrate that the goals they have
agreed on are realistic and
trustworthy in this regard it is crucial
to respect the principle of
technological neutrality when reaching
these targets
[Applause]
it is in our common interest to seize
the opportunities of the green and
digital
transitions of course balancing the cost
and benefits will remain crucial for the
success and acceptance by general public
in this in this respect we must ensure
the twin transition will bring benefits
to all groups of our citizens especially
communities which heavily rely on
employment in traditional uh industry
areas we must not leave anybody
behind honorable members
uh Europe is an everlasting task and
European nations are meant to live
together my country understands that
being part of Europe goes hand inand
with
responsibility so far the story of
Europe after the second world war has
been a story of
success therefore to remain competitive
on the global stage and to be able to
continue telling the story to Future
Generations I encourage all of us uh to
resist to war
fatigue I encourage all of us to
cooperate in unity and solidar
I encourage all of us to stand for our
European values and
principles and I encourage all of us uh
not to fall for false promises uh and
populism if we succeed in this Noble
Endeavor Europe will surely remain a
great place to live for our citizens
thank you very much for your
attention thank
you
[Applause]
for